Jeff Flake is a Republican senator I've
talked about him before recently he's
been I guess sort of like a slight voice
of reason within the context of the
nonsensical Republican Party you might
remember that when there was that
horrible truck attack in New York City
about five weeks ago Donald Trump
slammed Chuck Schumer for not having
changed a law that Trump incorrectly
blamed for that attack and Republican
Senator Jeff Flake was right there
saying hold on a second Republicans and
Democrats had a proposal to change the
law and senators from both parties
failed to actually make the change so
it's not Democrat Chuck Schumer's fault
he was right back in June Jeff Flake was
one of the Republican senators who said
that if Trump wants to continue
escalation with Syria military
escalation then there needs to be a vote
for a new AUMF an authorization to use
military force that using the
authorization for force from 2001 meant
to fight al-qaeda
was not going to cut it if Donald Trump
wanted continued military action in
Syria and then shortly after Trump's
inauguration Jeff Flake was one of a few
Republican senators who opposed the
majority Muslim country travel ban and
most recently he made news because he
gave this impassioned speech on the
Senate floor where he basically said
this is not normal what's going on under
Donald Trump and I am quitting the
Senate because this is so insane so the
point is Jeff Flake yeah he's still a
Republican I disagree with Jeff Flake on
most issues but he's had some moments of
pseudo integrity over the last year or
so we learned yesterday that Republican
Senator Jeff Flake donated to the
Democratic candidate in the Alabama
Senate race where the Republican
candidate is alleged serial child sex
abuse er Roy Moore tweeting a picture
did Jeff Flake of his donation check
where he wrote simply country over party
and it's a picture of a hundred dollar
check written out of his and presumably
this is his wife's account he and his
wife's accounts and Doug Jones later
thanked Jeff Flake for the donation on
Twitter saying thanks Jeff I hope others
will donate to hash
Tagg one-week hashtag right side of
history so listen this is not a story
for me to cheerlead Jeff Flake as
someone that progressives should support
but that's the incredible thing the
Republican Party has become so divorced
from even like the most basic modicum of
morality and ethics and they're so
embroiled in such extreme partisanship
that just me saying hey here's a
Republican who's not supporting the
serial alleged child molester it almost
sounds like in 2017 I'm saying this is
someone that I support politically which
is not true right in years past you
might have to go decades ago people
would disagree vehemently politically
but they would be more or less on the
same page in terms of hey Roy Moore Roy
Moore is accused by six people credibly
of sexual assault but let's put politics
aside and just say this isn't a good
potential Senator neither party wants
people with these credible allegations
against them to be serving in the Senate
politics aside at some point in American
history our lawmakers would have been
unanimous in saying presidential
candidate accused by more than a dozen
women of sexual assault including a
thirteen-year-old girl of rape ridiculed
Hispanics ridiculed Muslims ridiculed
the disabled reporter on and on
let's put politics aside and decide it's
bad for the country to support someone
like that but we've fallen so far from
that that when someone like Jeff Flake
merely says I'm not with the alleged
child sex predator regardless of my
party
some people will misinterpret that as me
saying I agree with Jeff flakes politics
that's not the case that's just not the
case at all and I think you know most
Republicans with any hint of integrity
left they're not gonna support Roy Moore
maybe they'll stay home if they're
voting in Alabama maybe they'll support
a write-in candidate but when you're de
facto supporting Doug Jones and I think
Jeff Flake is just going right to the
source here why beat around the bush
maybe I don't know that I agree with you
I think that Roy Moore has more actual
genuine support from Al
Republicans then I mean you're
presenting it not those with any
integrity left yeah right which is what
percentage of them I guess that'll find
out Jeff Flake is sort of like it's the
there's this term in the startup world
called the Minimum Viable Product which
is sort of like the minimum thing you
need to put together to be able to say
hey it's ready for some people to use
this that sort of applies here to Jeff
Flake in some sense we're not saying
that he has great views on taxation in
fact he voted in support of this
harebrained disgusting tax bill recently
we're not saying we agree with him on
social policy all we're saying is he
meets the absolute minimum criteria to
be a reasonable person which is that
he's just not going to support the
alleged serial child sex assault err
that's all and remember he's essentially
a lame duck I mean he's not running for
re-election in 2018 yeah so that's what
it took for him to be one of those
people absolutely
December 12th is election day in Alabama
December 11th is the deadline for post
marking absentee ballots in that
election if you're voting absentee a
donate phone Bank knock on doors donate
phone Bank knock on doors I don't know
that we realize that everybody realizes
the extent of the opportunity that there
is here to turn a very very red state
Alabama in and particularly a seat
previously held by the now Attorney
General Jeff Sessions into a democratic
seat it is a gigantic opportunity and
aside from that you've got an alleged
serial child sex assault er there who
might be the next senator from Alabama
let's not let it happen the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad